how long did it take you guys to perfect
the youtuber thumbnail face because god
come on we can't tangent already we
literally just started the topic okay
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no okay okay we don't talk
about that that's that's the hook that's
we'll start off with the tangent and
then we'll go back to the topic we'll
talk about that but in the meantime but
in the meantime how long did it take you
guys to perfect your youtuber thumbnails
no no okay you're asking the wrong
question why it's how long did it take
before you stopped becoming ashamed of
yourself doing the youtuber how how long
has it been since your soul died this is
okay this is a legitimate question
because i still suck at it because i do
anime though
you just open your mouth i do i do anime
thumbnails right
and so i my entire career has been like
anime thumbnails and so the few
videos that i film in live action i've
just been like a [ __ ] sheep in like
headlights your youtube face is like
my youtube face is just me looking
depressed because i don't know how to
make like any other face
why do you make your thumbnails look
like they're for ten-year-olds why is
your face open and gasping like an idiot
do you have a penis in your mouth or
something like that they were like
because the general demographic as a 10
year olds well no no so i you know i was
thinking and then the explanation is
unfortunately you guys won't click on it
the sad truth is that you know it works
um and it's something that you've come
to see
someone asked me when you take the
thumbnail thing you just depressingly
like sigh afterwards after you make the
pose and i'm like yes yes yeah
absolutely
there's nobody
there's no bigger like black mirror
moment than when you finish shooting
that thumbnail face shot and then you're
just like oh okay well now i've got to
go on with my life knowing i just did
that so it is depressing as [ __ ] yeah
but uh yeah i like to to me i just
because with thumbnails i feel like you
never perfect it on the first go it's
like i i feel like with thumbnails you
need 15 goals before you know what your
thumbnail style is right sounds like a
rookie really
well you're for you take wonder baby for
you it's [ __ ] easy
because now because now you've got
you've got like a cartoony thumbnails
where you want
you've got 850. that's when i'm too lazy
and then i get them too but also there's
some thumbnails where it's like i can't
possibly do a good enough job capturing
this so i'll do some nice little cheesy
clickbait with a character and some
drawings yeah what about you joey how
long how how long would you take on your
thumbnails or do you like do you make a
specific face
for that video or is it just as is it
just like a random screenshot from the
video you just filmed do you think you
make the best thumbnails out of trash
taste no who do you think makes the best
thumbnail
you think so yeah i think me who's got
the most views
i don't know
well i i think it's uh i think different
topics though
that's for sure
because you may think my thumbnails
[ __ ] suck i like mine a lot i like my
i think i like yours as well i think i i
get criticized the consistency isn't
there they're like i don't have a good
pattern but i also like that it's all
over the place a little bit i like it
you get a different art style every now
and then for me i feel a bit of a
double-edged sword if you develop a
pattern because then your thumbnails
start to look same but that's a good
thing because actually like if you
imagine you go and you you discover a
new youtuber right one of the biggest
things that puts me off is like i've
discovered a youtuber his content's
amazing and then i click on their
channel and it's like all over the
[ __ ] place and i'm just like what
what what is this channel trying to like
what is this channel's content you know
i feel like you like it's kind of like
an instagram page right where it's not
just about one photo it's about when
people click on your entire profile and
they
like consult i'm like we're like the
council getting around right yeah yeah
what do you think wait why why do you
think the reason your thumbnail wait did
you okay wait i have so many questions i
want to ask you okay i think that's what
you would be like my thumbnails suck why
would you why don't you upload them if
you think they suck because i can't make
better ones why don't you hire someone
ah it's the same thing with editing i
was like
i'm not good enough at this someone else
can take my jumbled mess of words
i can work with them they can get used
to my style and then we can go about it
i don't know then i feel like just like
completely detaches me from my content
i think that's a that's an excuse i
think the thumbnail is like the last
little bit of like me that i can put
into it right and it's like you are the
video though
you yeah that is true because like your
thumbnail style is you yeah it's your
face yeah right that that is that is
part i think it's also because i don't
even know what the [ __ ] i'm doing with
my thumbnails yeah as well like i don't
have like a pattern or anything like
that like i also switch between the
cartoon my avatar version of me and my
face and it's like like is it a 50 50
clear split or is it i i feel like it's
like it's mostly my it's mostly your
face now is it right the avatar when you
because before it used to be just my
avatar yeah i i think i understand
because it's one it's easier to rely on
an avatar you have a lot more room to
play with yeah and the expressions are
like set and it's cleaner yeah when it
went with your face you got to worry
about lighting you got to worry about
yeah yeah exactly i get it is it like
when you cannot get a good one with your
face you bring in the avatar no i just
give up and just use a [ __ ] oh if you
know i'm not happy with it no oh yeah i
work with what i've got basically yeah
you need you're gonna get a good good
artist or somebody work because i even
with my photos now when the when it's
just you'll notice that there's like
text in it yeah all the text is like
hand drawn yeah everything's all hand
done because i want to get it all to fit
nicely when you [ __ ] around with fonts
yeah you can probably do it yeah but i i
want to get everything perfect so i'll
talk with someone like let's reframe
this picture let's let's move things
around yeah just like just right so it
looks nice yeah because like you say you
you think you have the best thumbnails
and i think you definitely do for the
content you made and that's that's why
you found success and like i think i
don't know i'm gonna start my own day
here yeah yeah yeah
i feel like my thumbnails are like the
most optimized they can be for anime
style content that's true yes it's a
different yeah i've worked with a
different type of style of content yeah
yeah like if i'm cosplaying like
at the time of recording i recently used
a cosplay video yeah that's so easy to
like make a good thumbnail yeah just
literally get the picture of the cosplay
and then just have some whoa that's
that's me yeah yeah that's what i did
because it works exactly right
whereas whereas for me if you like 90 of
the time if you see a video recommended
on your youtube and it has like say a
waifu's face plastered right on the
front with a bunch of memes on the side
or something like that you're gonna know
it's my videos and you're not even gonna
need to see that it's my channel right
because it's a certain style that i've
built up right over the years i
backtrack second my own dick and i'll be
like we all make the best thumbnails for
what we do okay
okay we're all active
i'm sure somebody could make better
thumbnails for doing the same thing but
the thing though you can never think
like i've got it i've got it nailed
you've got to think like how do i make
it better yeah do i improve this all
right i want to make it pop more yeah
yeah
what is the worst thumbnail you think
you've made that you that you can
remember oh there's so many
yeah
have you ever
gone back and changed the thumbnail at
all no you've never
i i have like too lazy for that once i'm
done it's gone like that's it like i
don't wanna once the video's live i do
not wanna think i used to think about i
i used to think like that until i saw
that [ __ ] very tasty video that yeah
that said like he goes back and changes
the thumbnail and i tried it and it like
it actually makes a [ __ ] difference
yeah some videos that i actually changed
the thumbnail on title actually have
like a second wind and they're doing way
better than even when they initially
thinking to do it ever since that very
tasty video but i just haven't been
[ __ ] to do it basically
i was like yeah i'll get to it today
yeah yeah a lot of the older videos i
genuinely don't want people to watch
right right i'm like this is not the
content i make i do not want you
watching hours and hours of sebastian
prank calling and then being like when's
the next one coming out you know like
it's not it's not coming out it's never
coming out right i'm not doing it
anymore let me get out of this this
nightmare situation
i was just like you're about to say
something i was just like i was just
like you know what i don't think i can
relate
i was just like
you know what you know i like i was i
was in my head i was just like can i
relate to this can i relate to this
because i can't remember
who can relate to this
then i was just like the avatar like
that's rough buddy
most youtubers who get to this point
all that was going on my mind was just
like uh i'm sorry like i'm sorry that
happened to you but i'm not reading that
or something like that
oh i'm like i'm not happy for you or i'm
sorry for your loss but i ain't really
who get to this point have never had to
deal with that because that channel dies
[Music]
that's true because like i you know i
feel like one of the biggest things
you've done is you've definitely like
changed up your content a lot and you
know i you know you definitely like your
style and your
how you promote your videos and your
thumbnails have definitely changed along
the way
right so
you know it's it's it's a nice evolution
but for me like i've been around for so
long that uh there are still videos that
i'm proud of like years ago not every
video in minutes anime minutes oh that's
that's definitely coming back
eventually
it's it's this when's the next one going
it's uh it's uh it's like i'm it's just
like my hunter hunter you know it's just
it's just on hiatus
it was like six years yeah i know now
now i just feel bad whenever whenever a
manga is on hiatus because of you know
[ __ ] berserk right how much how big
of a meme that is and what that turned
into i saw an interview uh with iraqi
they had one that man works every day of
the week
yeah i bet he's like 60. yeah right this
man has never looks dirty he's never
going to stop no
it was insane i was like this man told
his weekly schedule and didn't mention a
break anywhere and he works from i think
10 a.m to 11 p.m with one hour break and
i'm like yeah
bro yeah that's what it takes man to be
the [ __ ] top shonen but like no no
wonder like he has so much musical
reference he doesn't have time to do
anything else because she's listening to
music
yeah like i can't imagine what the
actual life of a manga is like because
you see some youtubers on the grind
right but at least with youtube you can
you can have some variety in there you
can collab and you can do that i work
for a lot of content well i take breaks
yeah
well part of the part of the charm is
that your breaks also happen to be
monetizable right because you that's
like your twitch streams right because
that's that's for you that's your
downtime as well as work i guess
technically but with mangakas you can't
do anything but just draw and work on
your [ __ ] work in your series and i
can't imagine being that one tracked and
being that dedicated to just a single
thing in your life for that long i can't
dedicate what i can't dedicate like a
month of my life to one project let
alone [ __ ] five years or ten years